in previous videos on triangle
congruence we talk about how side side
angle cannot be used to establish
triangle congruence what i'll do in this
video is i'll show you an exception and
the exception is when we are dealing
with right triangles in particular when
this angle is a right angle
so this is a
90 degree angle
in which case this first side is going
to be the hypotenuse and the second side
is going to be a leg is going to be a
leg and that's why you'll sometimes see
this instead of called it you know
instead of calling it ssa for the
special case of a right triangle you'll
sometimes call this see this as
hypotenuse leg congruence
let me do some of the same colors so i'm
consistent so hypotenuse
hypotenuse leg
congruence and if you're dealing if
someone's saying there's a hypotenuse of
that triangle then that triangle by
definition is going to be a right
triangle you can only have a hypotenuse
in a right triangle and to get an
intuition for why two triangles are
going to be congruent if they're
hypotenuse if each of their hypotenuses
have the same length is it hypotenuse
hypotenuses if they have the same length
and then the leg has the same length we
can look at these two right over here so
we are going to assume that this
hypotenuse
that this
hypotenuse has the same length as that
hypotenuse let's say they're both of
length c
we can assume that this leg here has the
same
length
this leg here has the same length as
that leg we could call that length
a
and you can see that the only way to
draw the next side remember there's two
constraints now here we have to connect
to this point right over here we're
dealing with a triangle so we're only
going to have three sides
and it's a right triangle so it has to
be the next side i draw has to be
perpendicular
so the only way to draw that
the only way to draw that is just like
that and to feel good that i guess more
analytically that this side this green
side is congruent to this side we could
just use the pythagorean theorem the
pythagorean theorem
would tell us that this green side right
over here is going to be the square root
of the hypotenuse squared
c squared
c squared minus a squared minus the
square of the other leg
and this one is also going to be the
square root of c squared actually let me
just draw an arrow this is going to be
true for that and it's going to be true
and it's going to be true from that that
comes straight out of the pythagorean
theorem so from that we know that the
third leg
or the third side
that they
those two corresponding sides have to be
congruent and so that's where we get the
hypotenuse leg congruence from which is
really just a special case of ssa which
we said in the past you cannot apply
generally to establish triangle
congruence